vous voyez derrière moi la du bon beurre
d'arachide ça fait partie de nos
déjeuners
mais c'est également utilisé dans
plusieurs des aliments qu'on prépare
aussi visites par an bien sûr de
l'enfant allergique d'abord arrêter tous
pu écouter ça parce qu'il ya une étude
qui est publié dans un grand magazine
scientifique qui dit qu'on pourrait
adopter découvert un traitement contre
les allergies aux âges aux harrachis se
permet également de limiter les
symptômes
le docteur philippe bégin et
allergologue au chu sainte justine à lui
c'était du de là et tu peux nous en
parler bonjour docteur berger bon alors
dit dans un peu ça semblait tellement
une bonne nouvelle résumé nous
brièvement là les conclusions de l'étude
oui mais en fait donc la défense nation
alimentant pour les gens qui sont
allergiques
c'est quelque chose ça fait quand même
plusieurs années que qui est en
développement puis on se dit que ça
fonctionne sur une étude qui dit de
phase iii lorsqu'une grosse étude fait
dans 67 centres partout dans le monde
avec un très très grand nombre de
patients dans lequel on le fait
justement cette défense utilisation
alimentaire aux arrêts chez d'antan un
produit qui vont être éventuellement
commercialisés est ce qu'on fait
l'enfant c'est avec des doses prix paris
d' avance des régions on expose les gens
énergiques de façon très paisible
supervision médicale des plus de
quantités qui vont devoir manger tous
les jours et avec 18 h église et on va
voir les patients aux deux semaines à
peu près en clinique pour augmenter la
dose d'aliments qui vont devoir manger
tous les jours donc pour les surveiller
parce que demain son sont allergiques
donc bien potentiel de réaction esclaves
ainsi qu'à la longue ça va être désarmé
nos cellules d'allergies et on va se
rendre à l'écran d'une heure a su de
tous les jours sous le protéger contre
les actes d'un comté traces des riches
et de ce fait que au lieu de
potentiellement même mourir avec un
accident belle aux jeunes et rapides par
jour si alex n'avait qu'un une
contamination tracé il peut rien y peut
rien arriver donc les liban ben qu'on
voit à l'écran dans le moment c'est donc
dire qu'ils pourraient se gratter puis
prendre un bon morceau de gâteau
d'anniversaire lorsque toujours des
traces d'arachides seulement suffi pour
battre les ddt et garde un peu ce filet
de protection on paie jamais
complètement les gains en plongeant
d'art et rivera shepard
pardon d'arrêter de porter leur auto
injecteur d'adrénaline oui parce que si
on a enfin le ciment j'ai carrément 3 4h
id34 h il y avait quand même le tiers
qui allait réagir quand même il y avait
le le deux tiers qui même à 3 4h et ne
réagissait toujours pas avec un arraché
par jour à les protéger jusqu'à un peu
plus donc un petit tout d'esprit pour
les lits par an c'est si ma jambe pour
permettre aux avalats de participer aux
activités sociales ces images à part ça
on se saoule estime beaucoup le fardeau
du matin on se bat les réactions ce
n'est pas souvent que cela peut arriver
à tout moment a donc faut vraiment
qu'ils par aviva être la possibilité que
la réaction que presque tué leur enfant
la première fois pour y revenir à tout
moment que je suis donc l'impact est
majeur pour pour les résidents juste
deux mots très rapidement ce serait sous
forme de vaporisateurs qu'on pourrait
peut-être s'est dite inquiète préparés
d'avancé est ce que tu ne veux faire ou
pas ils vont apprendre à le vendre
quelque chose comme 2004 par hamid a
donc pour des pinottes littéralement
donc en face au dauphin d'un convoi
allait avec le produit qui étudient dans
l'étude du moins au québec mais le
principe est le même quand même donc
soif déçoit d'épeautre d'arachide ou du
sirop tronçonnage l'importance d'être
très précis dans la mesure très bien
alors dd dégagez dégagez votre emploi du
temps passant il ya quelques parents qui
vont vous appeler docteur merci beaucoup
de nous avoir donné ses explications ce
matin ça va mais des sourires sur les
visages de bien des mamans des papas
merci